pesquisadores da Meoclinic acabaram de
publicar no Lenset Neurology, é uma das
revistas médicas mais respeitadas do
mundo, um estudo com mais de 5.000
pessoas. Então eles desenvolveram uma
ferramenta preditiva que combina quatro
fatores principais: a idade, o sexo. Se
você carrega o gene apo que é
praticamente o gene maldito do
Alzheimer, e o mais importante de todos,
que é a quantidade de proteína
betamiloide que está se acumulando o seu
cérebro nesse momento. Então vocês todos
já ouviram falar na proteína milide, já
falei em vários vídeos no canal
e ela é como se fosse uma sujeira
grudenta que vai se depositando entre os
neurônios. E o que descobriram? Quanto
maior a quantidade dessa proteína medida
por um exame chamado petiamiloide,
usando uma escala chamada centiloide,
maior é o risco de você estar
desenvolvendo um comprometimento
cognitivo leve ou demência no futuro.
Yeah.